[Music]
on this Monday night Ontario's
prescription to reduce surgery wait
times the three-point plan for private
clinics the status quo is no working and
the apprehension overturning to
for-profit care Iran's regime
pinpointing protesters through cell
phone data they thought they'd received
the concerns a BC company was involved
and its response Rare Earth elements
Canada's goal to processed minerals
critical to Green Technology
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
Ontario's Premiere is promising to
reduce the long waiting list for surgery
by turning to Private health care
clinics the government is going to
publicly fund a range of procedures that
will be performed at private clinics to
ease the burden on hospitals it's
estimated 206 thousand people are
waiting for surgery in Ontario
Premier Ford says the plan will make it
easier and faster for those people to
access the help they need
they'll be paying for their parking but
no one is going to be paying any
additional cost they'll never use their
credit card they'll always use their old
whip card we're going to continue doing
that
Ford says it is time to start thinking
differently about the Health Care System
but there are questions about where the
doctors and nurses will come from and
whether this opens the door to the
privatization of Health Care in our top
story tonight turia isri explains the
plan and the reaction
yeah there we go tens of thousands of
ontarians are stuck on a surgery wait
list getting longer by the date the
premier in our government have been
clear
when it comes to your health the status
quo is not working the Ontario
government solution spent 18 million
dollars on expanding private clinics in
the delivery of Public Health Care a lot
of people out there they want to have
the endless debates about who should
provide care all our government cares
about is that you get the care you need
quickly and safely The Province unveiled
a three-step plan to clear the backlog
that's piled up in the pandemic starting
with an additional 14 000 cataract
surgeries performed in private clinics
the second phase will allow more private
clinics to offer CT Imaging
colonoscopies and endoscopies the third
phase will include hip and knee
Replacements my waitlist can vary
between 18 to 20 months anything that
means that we can get more operating
time and therefore cut those wait lists
down I think is is only beneficial to
the people of Ontario but Ontario's five
major health care unions oppose the move
and want more money spent on hospitals
instead what the for-profit clinics will
do is they will suction away resources
from our public sector to the for-profit
clinics prime minister Justin Trudeau
sidestepped a question about whether he
agreed with Ford's plan there are lots
of things that we're working on with the
provinces and I I look forward to being
able to announce positive steps forward
in the very near future the other big
question is Staffing critics of the plan
question where the government will find
health care workers to run these clinics
we don't have the people to do that work
right now
and we're going to be bleeding them out
into the private Health Care System
Colleen flood is a public health law
expert I think this is the wrong
prescription for the problem right at
the moment she's concerned there could
be added costs and not enough safeguards
recently we've had you know pretty
horrific examples of that with long-term
care so for-profit ownership of
Long-Term Care Homes publicly funded and
unfortunately that's where most of the
Carnage was she wants the province to
focus on strengthening Public Services
before it expands further into the
private sector tariya isri Global News
Ottawa
long waits for surgery have become the
standard instead of the exception in
this country last year across the 10
provinces it's estimated there was a
backlog of more than 1.2 million
procedures covid-19 had a major impact
on that hospitals performed nearly 600
thousand fewer surgeries during the
first 22 months of the pandemic compared
with 2019.
a small Canadian Telecom company is
being accused of allowing Iran to use
their software to spy on civilians a
report by citizen lab the digital and
Human Rights Watch group says the
company was involved in conversations
about setting up mobile services in Iran
in 2019. the contract was canceled
however as Mike jourlay reports citizen
Labs investigation highlights how Iran
is able to find loopholes even when
sanctions are in place in order to
strengthen its repressive tactics
Iranian activists learned the hard way
how dangerous a smartphone can be during
a brutal Crackdown on protests Iranian
security forces have used protesters own
cell phone data to track them down they
thought they were safe and at 70 and
there are all these people knocking on
their door and arresting them which
turns out is through the data that they
have collected through different means
different apps in a report released
Monday the digital human rights
organization's citizen lab detailed how
Iran's complete control over its mobile
network gives authorities access to user
information including texts and internet
usage what we've witnessed you know as
you know an overall you know platform
surveillance and control platform that
Iran has it's extremely powerful you
know they do have ultimate control but
Iran couldn't build its system without
help and through purported leaked emails
from tehran-based ariantale citizen lab
says it uncovered several companies
including British Columbia based at
porta-1 that were approached for their
technology in a statement through their
lawyer Porter one did not deny an
unnamed sales agent engaged in talks
with Ari Intel in 2018 but when the deal
was submitted for approval a Portuguese
company was listed on the bill of sale
an immediate investigation by Senior
Management revealed that a Portuguese
company was a front for ariantel any
suggestion that poor to one has supplied
software which is used to intercept or
surveil calls in Iran is false
Portal 1 says payment was returned and
the contract was formally canceled in
2019.
ariantel did not respond to questions
despite sanctions limiting its strategic
Partners from many countries including
Canada Iran was successful in building
out its Telecom system a fact not lost
on activists who need their phones to
connect but understand the risk they're
taking and they have I'm not saying that
these haven't been effective but there's
still like loopholes and we have to
actively and proactively try to cut
these and close these people not to
allow people with money
to come and do whatever they want and in
turn Empower Iran to spy on those who
dare to disagree microlight Global News
Toronto
you can find more detail including
information about how Iran continues to
evade sanctions on our website
globalnews.ca global national Searchers
in Nepal have found the cockpit voice
recorder and flight data recorder from
that plane that crashed on Sunday with
72 passengers and crew on board both
recorders are said to be in good shape
the yeti Airlines flight crashed as it
approached the airport in the city of
Pokhara an airport spokesperson says
visibility was good at the time and the
pilot did not report anything untoward
as he prepared to land no one is
believed to have survived it is Nepal's
deadliest plane crash in 30 years
at least 40 people are now confirmed to
have died in that Russian attack on an
apartment building in denipro Ukraine a
memorial across the street from
Saturday's deadly airstrike is growing
neighbors lit candles and laid flowers
for the victims who include a 15 year
old dancer a boxing coach and two young
mothers humanitarian Aid is also being
collected
the missile leveled part of the
building's nine stories about 7 200
metric tons of debris have been cleared
so Rescuers and search dogs can scour
the site dozens of people are still
unaccounted for Hope is fading that any
survivors will be found many of those
who did survive or badly heard in the
hospital Russia claims its forces did
not Target a residential building it
claims the devastation was triggered by
Ukrainian counter missiles the attack is
the deadliest in moscow's three-month
campaign to hit Ukrainian cities away
from the front lines
and today a shopping area in the
occupied Donetsk region was pounded by
shelling Crews pulled down parts of this
building so they could safely search for
survivors at least three people were
injured in the attack there are fears
more people might be pinned under the
debris
now to a disturbing story out of the
United Kingdom a metropolitan police
officer has admitted to being a serial
rapist who preyed on women for 18 years
he's pleaded guilty to 49 offenses
including rape false imprisonment and
indecent assault and he's not the first
cop facing charges like that as our
Europe bureau chief Crystal gemancing
Reports the case is further damaging
public confidence in London's police
force
we commend all of the victims for their
bravery and coming forward and would
like to thank them for their courage in
being prepared to take the stand to see
Justice served outside this other
Courthouse prays for the strength of 12
women victims of David Carrick a 48 year
old metropolitan police officer who used
his job to gain the trust of women who
he violated while using the power of his
badge to keep them silent Herrick held a
role where he was trusted with the
responsibility of protecting the public
yet over 17 years in his private life he
did the exact opposite Carrick admitted
to a list of offenses including 24 rapes
nine counts of sexual assault and three
counts of coercive and controlling
behavior all of his crimes are now
public after he entered guilty pleas on
the remaining charges against him he was
nicknamed Dave I want to understand how
if you can't recognize the Predator
across the desk from you how you're
supposed to recognize the predators in
the public the Metropolitan Police
acknowledge Phalanx when it comes to
Carrick officers were aware of at least
nine reports including an allegation of
domestic abuse Carrick however wasn't
suspended until after his arrest in 2021
the woman who reported him for rape was
apparently spurred on following the
murder of Sarah everard everard was
kidnapped raped and murdered in 2021 by
Wayne cousins he was also a met police
officer cousins and Carrick were in the
same unit again there are demands for
the UK's largest police force to oust
unfit officers so I can never guarantee
that there isn't another sex offender
within the um within the Metropolitan
Police Service but what I can say with
obsolete confidence is that we are
determined and that we are doing so much
to identify who those officers may be
care Eric will be sentenced for his
crimes next month Crystal gomancing
Global News London
Canada's journey to cleaner energy
coming up with the federal government
has just on to help shift away from
fossil fuels plus a super reward for a
man dubbed the Buffalo blizzard hero
in Germany climate activists trying to
stop the expansion of a coal mine were
cleared out today
officers moved in using water cannon and
batons to drive out hundreds of
demonstrators they've been occupying a
village that will be demolished to allow
the expansion of an already huge Coal
Mine the activists say digging up and
burning the coal will severely undermine
Germany's efforts to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions the push towards clean
energy means Rare Earth elements are
being made a priority for investment and
exploration plus production and
processing as part of Canada's critical
minerals strategy today the federal
government approved an environmental
assessment for a lithium mine in Quebec
as Mackenzie gray explains it's just one
small step as Canada shifts our energy
priorities
from electric vehicles to smartphones
critical minerals are at the heart of
future technological advances and Canada
is trying to become a world leader
Canada has incredible amounts of the
critical minerals and The Rare Earth
elements that the world needs the feds
have pledged 3.8 billion to help the
sector fund exploration and to cover the
cost of new applications to the
government it's speeding up the approval
process that the industry says will be
key to Future growth a more focused
review that looks at those aspects that
are absolutely critical and unique about
that project
and not looking at everything under the
sun would make for a more streamlined
process the first step of that new plan
in action today with the impact
assessment agency of Canada announcing
they've approved an environmental review
of the lithium Mine in Northern Quebec
the James Bay mine which is hoping to
open in 2024 is now subject to 271
conditions around wildlife and
Indigenous rights it will give some of
our allies some confidence that we are
able to you know attract investment get
some approvals move through the
regulatory process but in terms of
meeting what we need to accomplish with
our strategy we need about 10 times more
of these Canada has only one other
lithium mine which is owned by a Chinese
firm that ships all of its material back
to China Beijing dominates this space
with a third of the world's nickel over
half of the lithium and 87 percent of
rare Earth elements that has helped
Drive their manufacturing sector China
is has been in that space for a long
time and it could have been beneficial
for us ending Reliance on China could be
big business with the International
Energy agency estimating demand for
critical minerals could increase
six-fold by 2040.
that opportunity spurred the prime
minister to visit Asia in late 2022
pitching Allied countries that Canada
could help provide raw materials to help
shift away from China so they're not
like our companies that are publicly
traded that are profit sensitive
that have to make money China can invest
for strategic reasons the James Bay
project still has multiple approvals to
go both federally and provincially
before it can open but this does put the
liberal promise to the test that they
would speed up the approval process in
the critical mineral space Mackenzie
gray Global News
Ottawa
30 years on the Run ahead how one of
Italy's biggest crime bosses was finally
caught
[Music]
there was cheering on the streets of
Palermo Italy today as the country's
most Wanted Mafia bus Mateo De Niro was
arrested he spent 30 years as a free man
wanted for numerous murders and
convicted in absentia including for the
torture and killing of a boy as Redmond
Shannon reports Italy's Prime Minister
says though this arrest is considered a
victory the war against the mafia is far
from over
[Applause]
Sicilians thank police as news emerges
that they have finally arrested Mateo
dinaro Italy's most Wanted Man picked up
at a private Hospital in Sicily's
Capital Palermo a boss of Casa Nostra
the Island's notorious Mafia group
I was incredulous shocked but happy says
this local man dinaro is being kept at a
secret location and is unlikely to see
Freedom again in 2002 he was convicted
in absentia of being involved in crimes
that include bombing attacks the murder
of two State prosecutors and the torture
and killing of a 12 year old boy
one Sicilian lawmaker told Global News
it is above all a symbolic day for
Sicily I mean the damage that this guy
and these guys have done to the millions
of good Sicilians all over the world
it's enormous why why it took 30 years
to find him and how he could have been
hiding in Sicily our questions
authorities need to answer
Italian Prime Minister Georgia Maloney
says it is a day for Italians to
celebrate but insists the war against
the mafia has not been won kozanostra
isn't what it was but organized crime
remains a problem in Italy one
notoriously difficult to tackle so now
we have to consider and this is the
basic question what will happen will he
cooperate with the judicial Authority or
not judicial sources say 60 year old
dinaro was being treated for cancer he
was already sentenced to life in jail 21
years ago so there may be little
incentive left for him to reveal the
remaining secrets of cosenostra Redmond
Shannon Global News London
a buffalo man is being recognized for
his life-saving efforts during
December's dangerous blizzard on
Christmas Eve mechanic Jay Whiteley
helped rescue more than 20 people who
were trapped in their cars he'd already
spent one night sleeping in his truck
and then he sought Refuge by breaking
into a nearby school once he was
comfortable he went back out into the
storm to find others in need of shelter
this weekend the Buffalo Bills presented
him with tickets to the Super Bowl as a
thank you from the whole community and
that is global national for this Monday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada
is the Peace Bridge that spans the Bow
River in Calgary Alberta we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you